hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to grave an indie horror
game that promises dynamic environments
spawning and if dynamic environment
spawning means procedurally generated
then I am very interested in this horror
game one thing that I did notice as soon
as I loaded up that even though there's
a death of death and destruction it
looks awfully nice there's a lot of
detail put into this and I've been
pretty lucky because this week I've been
able to play some actually high-quality
indie horror games which there's been a
rather um drought of there's been a lack
of really high-quality ones so I'm eager
to give this one a try just kind of 100
was I was that me what was that a breezy
breezy over here someone wanna say whoa
oh oh is that a thing well I think
that's a thing hey well hi okay I'll
I'll move on you breathe on you okay
hi-oh to TV some little girl gonna pour
out that TV and talk to me about rings
and such I'm not ready for marriage you
get out of here oh whoa cool I can throw
it haha I wasn't even sure what happened
hey buddy uh you okay you okay in there
alright I'll move on well how many
matches do I have the counter in the
bottom says one match is zero so I guess
I'm winning against the matches Oh what
that was not there before what the hell
let's go okay okay the LSD is kicking in
I'm losing my mind
you know oh oh you're still breathing in
there
you all right need a match
I got matches jump that is the
assump look I'm jumping like two inches
off the ground
what is I swear I'm stronger than hey
buddy you want some matches maybe they
might help with your breathing problem
are you pretty good okay I guess I have
unlimited matches now or maybe I just
got the giant box of a thousand matches
so either way I'm gonna follow these
railroad tracks into this mine lookin
thingy I don't know if this is all
randomly generated if this is just kind
of a layout here I didn't read the
instructions very well that's a pretty
common okay dark real quick I got that
real quick that's a pretty common theme
with me because I am dumb
I am the dumb and I don't read
instructions when they are given to me
oh oh cool so I actually have some light
in here I wonder how long until they
turn off because that's a pretty common
theme in these horror games God that is
pretty this is made on the Unity engine
by the way but I don't really call a
Unity engine looking quite like this
that's very nice
I like the ominous glow of read from my
match awful walls is delightful okay
anyways enough harping about the game
itself oh I called yo you think you can
mess with me I've screamed in the face
of thousands of horror monsters you
think you are worthy I didn't run best
not to taunt the monster before I meet
him as I'm sure that there is one in
here this would be a great layout like I
love I don't know if this is
procedurally generated because he didn't
say it was
it just said didn't dynamic environment
spawning but I do love it because SCP
containment breach containment breach is
one of my favourite games it's more
matches right I already have matches I
throw myself to my death
I can't even jump over that ledge I'm
that wimpy I'm like a bodybuilder than
only focused on upper body trick so I
got like giant Titanic muscles but on my
legs are just little twigs oh oh cool
okay that's yours Oh what was that whoa
oh okay I need not be freaked out about
that that was just a little hole nice
ceiling yeah bit what anybody there okay
Oh who's there somebody want to mess
with me I'm on matches I didn't think so
shut up
I heard that stomping around the mud
over there building sandcastles right
why ain't that delightful our railroad
tracks holes to go somewhere is this
wily coyote where I painted a run on the
never mind people dry don't even know
who wily coyote is anymore
right then their mouths up there
you gotta get me you all get some
matches up the butt okay fine
haven't seen anything yet so I'm
assuming they're waiting on it till I
get to where I'm supposed to go what is
it okay what is it what is it what is it
I'm probably scarier than anything in
this game but I just I just shatter my
leg one of my twig legs just broke in
half and I kind of love limping now
who's that what is that
still broken pillar fingers why why is
going I don't like to smell this I don't
like the cluster probably out of this oh
oh well okay I was expecting that I was
gonna be in the caves for a while unless
it was just a red herring and I'm not
really high the caves yet which way was
I supposed to go is that my first choice
what is that oh it's a power line I keep
going what is that and they're perfectly
logical answers okey-dokey so what
wouldn't what is happening why is it
shadow no no no baby shadow I'm going
I'm ready as I can the shadow giving up
on me is that a bad thing is that
there's a Sun going down oh no idea what
is that what is this thing to see you
with her stop it you stop that I don't
know what's going on to you
I'm sorry
it looks like the belly button piercing
on a very big lady you know what I mean
okay the shadow stop creeping and now
I'm going up to another tusky dusty oh
that is so pretty okay sorry I got
freaked out for a second
okay you know my expectations on these
organs are very low when I play them so
when they're delightful and look
fantastic I like I like really liked
them
this is awesome I really like it and the
environment is cool too like the Dust
Bowl is not a common theme in any horror
game that I played before
maybe Walden it what is that is that a
can of gasoline so I can burn this barn
down to the ground they shouldn't give
me this what what are they serious well
this I can burn things oh oh well that's
not oh come on I was really hoping for
something there maybe my Sookie yeah no
oh you can't just gimme gasoline and God
give me the option to burn everything I
see I'm like a pyromaniac now you why
did it get dark all of a sudden where's
the power
okie dokie those matches do not last
long on the ground they do not last long
but in my hand I can apparently hold
them forever with them
okay well that's out of place one of
these things it's not like the other one
of these things just doesn't belong Oh a
flashlight okay that somehow made it
much worse I suddenly got all these
Vietnam flashbacks about Slenderman
Oh your while you're a thing gracias
thing why are you saying you ah can I
burn you alive hey Brett back oh I'm
doing much what do I do
do I get the gas can what do we do huh
huh where's go you still that girl burn
burn burn baby burn it up ah it didn't
burn fast enough we going on how do I
beat you oh maybe I'll climb up in the
barn very frazzled right now because I'm
I'm I'm I'm at a loss for what to do
give me a second wait maybe if I lead
them over the fire that I created there
come on buddy you know you want to step
into the flames here you go huh
good you go buddy Wow we'll keep to is
doing that how do you lose does ever
I'll burn you live Breckinridge I've
ever liked one fire burn Biden burn
Dean my butt is he eating my butt Oh see
for checkpoint it saved my soul well
that was the first death let's get back
into it let's run again leaders rarely
I'll do it wrong oh they're getting
damaged was I get him dabbled i don't
recall anything hitting me but I seem to
have lost health I wasn't watching my
health meter down there okey-dokey well
Oh with where's the guy
where's gasoline I don't even know if
the gasoline really helped me but I want
it there's a flashlight okay things
aren't bad yet cuz that what is that
batteries oh it's one of those big
battery flashlights the one with the
very girthy thingy on it woo oh okay I
thought that was like a body up there I
got a flare got through two more flares
nobody wants to mess with me bing-bong
bring it on okay burnin family that's
not a thing I can do but if someone
wants to mess with me they're gonna be
awfully chuffed chuffed
I think chuffed is a British word Ferb
excited what is that word everything in
Britain is so weird chuffed
I'm awfully tough to see this scenario
I'm gonna go see what this big glowy
thing was no I need to find the gas
first
Tina where's the gas Co thing prolly not
gonna trigger until I find the gas go we
did it go there's a little blow to ball
give me my gasps what gasps anybody
seriously where the hell do I go to find
it shut up I'm gonna go out and see what
that thing is I can't find the gas out
there then I'm just squat out of luck
what the hell are you why are you
shaking the ground good
lordy Lou you are massive you're like
one of the flash bang a flash bang I
seem to be getting the idea that these
things don't like light but what is this
thing
holy hell that's awesome it's like one
of those gates are ba ba ba ba ba with
your videos little things I mean your
hand ran it's one of those things from
Mass Effect you know what I'm home Oh
get dark okay I guess it's time for the
monsters to come out and play
don't worry I got a flashbang with your
name on it sonny jim
you want a tussle with my mate what is
that
who are you no no I got a sigh fine
you get banged what the hell did I do
ah the most useless thing I've ever seen
ah well how about doing anything I don't
think I was doing anything brainy Lou
he's breathing all over me I don't like
it I don't much care for it
what is that what is that a lamp ah okay
why what why why is this here why it's
another flash bang that don't do jack my
baby I'm back
why am i shooting my thing like a gun
baby I got your daddy words go where did
he go
well I guess I'll just take a break and
watch some TV
good you go I heard your breathing uh
your baby better am i shooting it what
why any sense I don't know I don't know
but that thing's kind of going crazy
over there where'd you go
yeah yeah ba ba ba ba ba is this is this
actually doing anything this is not
that's not doing a Maggie what about
that thing I don't know what I'm
supposed to know yeah
wait it did that no okay
it was just already doing that yeah baby
oh it is working didn't work on that
other guy though ah suck on that boy
it's gonna burn it yeah you get some
took my life tonight oh yeah that's
right that's right war that's a pretty
sky okay so my chuff mist levels are at
maximum my jimmies are unrivaled
gotta just hear the breathing dokie
that's good hey you stop by it's a
double to double whammy rare you good to
Jacquet ha ha cha cha cha alrighty then
so what was up with the red guy
hey don't you do that Oh out of here
instantaneously cuz the sun's coming up
apparently I turned on the generator or
not cuz I don't have any gas Oh was I
supposed to pour gas in the generator
not on the ground like a I'm just
an idiot it was like burn burn
everything alive and I was supposed to
put it in the thing and okay so now what
it's daylight now and the Sun I didn't
know that the Sun actually moves through
the sky like that but now what seriously
now what I don't know there's gotta be
something to do with this oh great
bellybutton ring of the gods
tell me what I must do and I shall
probably do it maybe I'm gonna head back
because there was another way to go out
the cave and I can't really find
anything else here
oh oh I apparently done something wrong
what are you going on oh goodness what
what no I can't leave no let me leave
you bastard I want to go home
No oh goodness
well apparently I'm gonna be here awhile
so I better get comfortable maybe there
was some all that happened quickly or
the forest go before is disappeared the
forest fast huh okay alright I'm not
going crazy the forest disappeared the
big floppy thump over there bellybutton
ring of the Gods is gone oh no you know
why is this not hurting you
oh yeah Bob I'm out of batteries after
this so I'm gonna have to make do with
whatever I have else I don't even think
I have gas it's that guy it's a red guy
the one that is ineffective way
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba die die already
okay so come on bring it on bah-bah-bah
I really I'm shooting we sing like a gun
it's almost hilarious if it wasn't
ridiculous another flashlight
that didn't do anything for me I already
have a flashlight I don't need another
one but I do need more batteries where
can I get more batteries or a gas can
that would be nice to be doing why am i
doing hey hey you want to back up a tad
where are you boy yourself I got a
flashlight I'm armed and slightly
slightly chuffed politely jump myself
this levels you know a mess with I'm
gonna flare now Oh Melanie I'm serious
business right oh that's a guy I don't
want to mess with a guy I don't think I
want to mess with a guy anyway because I
don't think I can kill the guy we do I'm
gonna mess with the guy cuz I got
nothing better to do
there's more than one guy oh you're
pretty weird not being really in weird
oh okay that was a mistake it was a bit
of a mistake
let's do I have flashbang I don't think
if flashbang gonna do much for them Oh
shut up I got a match hey hey hey Man
Man Man oh this is bad what is that oh
that's my yeah I guess the guy hey don't
thank you
generator won't work I'm trapped huh
maximum justice engaged oh wait there's
a thing over there I see nothing over
there no is that the same place I'm just
in that's the same town I don't know I
don't know yeah
wait no shut up shut your mouth that is
that is that is something else that
might be the same exact this is just
looping back and forth forever
oh no am I gonna be trapped here for the
rest of eternity know what I mean what
excuse me oh that was hatch
oh I wanted to play more but oh all
right so that was grave that was
actually really cool I misunderstood
it's not procedurally generated I think
but still it was very interesting I
liked it very detailed
not too shabby if I have to say so but
the gun shooting flashlight mechanic was
a little bit wonky they could work on
that one but either way great if you
want to play it for yourself there's a
link in the description or obviously the
website's right there if you want to see
more horror videos that I've done click
the annotation over there
it's a giant playlist like 140 videos
for you to check out and if you got more
suggestions for good horror games that
you want me to play in the future let me
know in the comments thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video